according to the medical examiner the
ketamine and Perry system caused both
cardiovascular over stimulation and
respiratory depression respiratory how
you get a sad breathing that's what
that's what it is it's that your
breathing got sad how you get a sad
[Music]
breathing and this just in Matthew Perry
died from acute effects of
ketamine that's actually oh yeah because
he he passed away for a while and no one
knew the cause of it but then now pickle
ball but now it's the pickle ball yeah
cuz he's playing pickle ball and then
they got TI he got tired from pickle
that's what a lot of people were saying
people were saying he died you know
dehydrated from the pickle ball or
something but now it's yo I've seen some
pickle ball games it gets really intense
I wouldn't be surprised he be sweating
and you get in a [__] hot tub you
know [__] pass out but I guess not
it's ketamine related huh you think it's
like a you guys ever done ketamine
before I think Joe has is it
self-induced OD it's pretty sick wait
what's sick about ketamine it's it's
what ketamine did to his body it's not
about him actively doing ketamine he
used to do ketamine oh oh so it's the
after effects of it he didn't overdose
on it cuz that's what I was going to say
is I've done a lot and I've never
overdosed but I got into what was called
the khole and when you're in the khole
you're walking a straight line but it
feels like you're going diagonal and
it's kind of like those videos you see
on people on fentanyl where they're like
leaned over but you're not really leaned
over you're actually walking straight
but you feel like you're leaned over
it's pretty [__] up I hear the khool
is the goal though like people no it
feels like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa It's like that
[__] carnival ride when you're in the
spinny Spin and you're like why am I
spinning when I'm just sitting and I
just want to chill man Gravitron or
whatever oh yeah cuz what I was reading
with sorry you can take away no no
please cuz like he not PVP something
with it's not PVP but no something like
cuz a lot of people have this there's a
[__] like um TMZ thing about this
right now where it's like he died of
camine and that's what saying but it's
it's what it did do his cardiov vascular
system so it's some it was like the
negative effects after he done it after
years at the moment no that well he had
he they were using it to like treat him
like a little bit but but he died from
like what happened to his heart so when
when um when you have those
complications you're supposed to take
like ketamine to cope with it well
ketamine is just a tranquilizer it's
called ketamine infusion therapy for
depression and anxiety but doing this a
week and a half before his death the way
I did it is we got it from a pharmacy in
Mexico okay and it comes in a liquid
vial you put it on a plate you pour the
liquid vial on the plate you boil a
[__] pot of water it boils up and
then it heats the plate up it evaporates
it it crystallizes you chop it up turns
it into powder form and then you sniff
it I'm pretty sure that's not how he did
it yeah because the difference between
what you do with that one and this one
is in that one right after you sniff it
you buy a plane right you take it all it
doesn't feel like infusion therapy yeah
it's not like essential oils that's
snorting therapy so according to the
medical examiner the ketamine and Perry
system caused both cardiovascular
overstimulation and respiratory
depression respiratory how you get a sad
breathing that's what that's what it is
it's that your breathing got sad how you
get a sad breathing yeah Anthony answer
that [__] question yeah Anthony host
host away his lung goes like
this and they don't want to breathe in
Air anymore no they're just sad they're
like life is depressing I want to do
this so it's it's not a overdose the
medical examiner found no evidence of
alcohol methamphetamine cocaine heroin
PCP or fentanyl contributory factors in
paries death including drowning coronary
heart artery disease and berrin effects
which is a something used to wean
addicts of op off opium so it's mostly
mostly his heart okay so it's like he
had heart disease but that's what that's
the [__] of this right now people
going he Academy it's like that's
literally if you scroll through TMZ you
you're left with only that cuz what's
the sexor headline that he died from
like heart disease stuff or acute
effects of it because he had to go
through like infusion therapy and like
what it's like when you're weaning off
of a drug and they prescribe you with
something so that you can like survive
the weaning and then you die during that
period and then everyone goes oh you
were taking it again you failed yeah cuz
all the comments were saying the
comments were all full of that they were
like people like why would you prescribe
someone ketamine that's desperately
trying to be off ketamine that doctor's
idiot like it's Nick dun he's an idiot
[__]
[__] I'm glad that you said that cuz I
didn't understand either yeah damn I
don't it's like I knew this last week by
the way I just read about it he finds
gems though you know he just knows
Advance why would they tarnish his name
like that he died a poor guy they're
just using his name tabl [__] to get
clicks TMZ should [__] burn to the
ground
what
but then we're using the same headline
too we got eat we
got on our thing we should write the
correct story there you go k me K me K
me there you go it's so boring he just
had heart complications and he passed
away rip so so also according to the
medical examiner Perry had been
undergoing ketamine infusion therapy
every other day for some time but 6
months before he passed a new doctor
decided per was doing well enough that
he didn't need the treatment as often
and the report does not say how
frequently Perry was getting ketam
infusion therapy in the months before he
died I wonder if that's similar to like
if you died of lung cancer on a day that
you had like a piece of Nicorette in
your mouth and people are like you
should have just quit
idiot he put it on himself nicotine
poisoning yeah and then Nicorette gets
like [__] lawsuits and [__] yeah wow
damn dude well I mean people don't like
to read so they'll read a whole sentence
and go I know everything now it feels
even sadder because it it looks like he
was like now that you've said that now
it's like showing that he was in the
process of trying to better himself you
know like it wasn't like he was a
Resurgence of old habits as everyone's
kind of trying to make it look like he
had a lifelong battle with drugs right
is that story so he actors love cocaine
and parting well why wouldn't you though
you know what I mean like if you get in
that world I think it's like and if you
make it when you're like 25 and you're
getting like $20 million an episode or
whatever the [__] they were getting what
was the last big hit that he did though
17 Again the big hit the Friends reunion
you're so fast for these movies man dude
I know it's probably just friends cuz I
think uh what was the last thing they
negoti 17 Again was it no what's that
one movie where he was a teacher cuz
there was like a million dollars a
episode per cast member nothing's going
to be that yeah in like in the '90s well
or early 2000s he's in his 30s so like
then like you're just so [__] rich
and then I think I read some crazy stat
it was like um all of them after that
got paid at least I think 10 million a
year for the rest of their life
syndication yeah something crazy why do
you think yeah so many celebrities have
to turn to a life of drugs and addiction
because it's like one of those thrill
seeking things once you go a certain
level like regular [__] isn't enough
anymore to keep [__] at rockars dude
we all know actors and celebrities and
we know the the lowest tier ones yeah
yeah probably sure yeah oh you can see
why he wants he's back though that guy's
kind of coming up again he's coming up
yeah he's blown up we should have him on
maybe he won't disrespect our office
this time yeah we
vacuumed so all six of them make uh $20
million annually so that's split up
amongst all of them right now until the
rest of their lives 20on no no together
yeah 20 million divided by six divided
by six and at the time it was a million
for makes it for 3 million every single
year 2024 2025 2026 it's insane it just
seems like crazy when I mean like not
not only celebs but like let's say you
have you just have all money all the
time that you can burn if you feel
discomfort if you feel sad if you feel
like anxiety and you know money okay
makes you feel better you know that
money's just right there to fix the
problem artificially why wouldn't you do
that you have a surplus you can party
every night and not run out of money
yeah that's crazy do you think that then
having money is a curse for some people
yeah I don't know but watch try me
somebody just give me unlimited money
let me just see I bet I could prove them
wrong hey if you really hate this guy
send him a lot of money that get him
good be good guys I deserve it I think
it's definitely a curse if that's the
only thing that you know I think it's a
curse if you don't know how to handle it
you know like people that are born into
wealth and they don't even know anything
else that sucks the aises and erors yeah
yeah cuz they're all pieces of [__] kind
of well that's why Bill Gates and all
them guys who are great people they want
to um donate all the all the kids money
like Warren Buffett's doing that he's
donating all his kids wealth yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's no like like there's
no
inheritance so is that Ashton Kutcher
and M Aston kman yeah munas yeah do you
guys know any buddy who's um a kid I
guess who is born into like a super
super rich family who's like very
spoiled I do but I can't name him but I
will say this they're pieces of [__]
kind of yeah they're they're they're
totally they think that like the world
is like revolves around them kind of
thing it's not such a stereotype thing
but but it's true yeah you can't blame
them for being out of touch yeah it's
just it's just their circumstances and I
I like them for who I know them to be
but I don't like them for how ignorant
they are about who they are in a way
yeah so I don't hang with them much but
isn't that all relative like what is out
of touch if we like go to like a rich
person's Community like when we be the
people out of touch you know what I mean
yeah that's true it just depends on
which world you're hanging out in it's
all that's true yeah for sure cuz like
we can go to like you know the ghettos
or whatever and be like you guys are out
of touch oh [__] we should do that you
go to you go to house and they got like
17 forks and [__] you're like I don't
want how to use all these things it's
like yeah I'm out of touch but then when
you look at it from the spectrum of like
where they sit in the percentages and if
they're right there at the tip at the
0.1 and that's the only people they
relate with that to me is out of touch
that's called lucky baby I think I think
then with the rest of the planet it's
like if you can't even find the mean and
like see what this guy's talking about
understand like the average yeah I just
need upper middle class that's all send
me your money so I can test this
curse yeah we have a GoFundMe for
Anthony's experience to get him to
middle class I heard I heard a Matthew
Perry story that he told that was pretty
pretty funny he said that he um he's at
a party one night and he said M Night
shamalan walks in and he's like hey
night holy [__] and then like the guy
walks over and like they're like they're
having a good time and stuff and he said
that he was cracking night up like the
whole night he's like I for some reason
just everything I'm saying is landing
and landing and Landing with with Knight
and so he's like he's like and then and
then Knight's like hey let's go to like
this other club across the street and so
Matthew Bar's like sure let's [__] go
and so then like on the way there he's
like dude he's like I'm cutting up and
chopping up with night this is like I
could be a I'm going to be a [__]
movie star like after friends I'm going
to be a [__] movie star I'm I'm going
to
Parlay well then he gets to this next
place and he goes up to his buddy he's
like dude I've been hanging with and
chamon all the time and his buddy's like
that's not [__] M ni shame it just
some fan shut up that's so F just some
Indian fan oh no that he thought was he
thought was show [__] oh no and then
after that they became great friends
where he was like oh get out of here
yeah you have no power get out of my
life you're not a director oh that's
sad it was retesh
dude the whole time the Indian guy's
like I'm going to make it dude yeah dude
well cuz apparently Matthew Perry told
him we should work together and then the
guy was like what the
[Music]
[__]